[Music]
have you ever wondered what the flag of
your country really represented well
take a look at 20 of them so you'll
learn more about your culture and also
what matters the most to people all
around the world make sure you stay
tuned until the end so that you won't
miss your favorite country if your
country was part of this list don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you 20 flags of the world and
the stories behind them USA most people
watching this video come from the United
States of America this is why we want to
start with this one as long as you stay
until the end of this video you probably
know the horizontal red and white
stripes represent the 13 colonies that
declared independence Connecticut
Delaware Georgia Maryland Massachusetts
New Hampshire New Jersey New York North
Carolina Pennsylvania Rhode Island South
Carolina and Virginia the 50 stars also
represent the 50 current States of
America but did you know that there have
been 28 versions of the flag that we all
know since 1775 with different numbers
of stars and stripes it takes a lot of
work to get the perfect result okay guys
we are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup hacks and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know
these are the common affection he left a
hairpin you see you there
Liberia don't you think that this flag
looks just like the one we have seen
before that's because they actually used
it as an inspiration abolitionists
wanted freed slaves to return to Africa
so they purchased the land they call it
Liberia inspired by the words Liberty
just like the USA the comi proclaimed
its independence and a national flag was
needed this time the number of stripes
represented the number of men who signed
the Liberian Declaration of Independence
a star was also used to show that they
were the only independent western-style
state in Africa but unlike Americans
they kept the same flag first century
and a half even though people asked for
a new design inspired by African
countries Canada Oh Canada our home and
native land Oh Canada what does your
flag represents also called the maple
leaf flag the leaf has only been added
in 1965 when Prime Minister Lester B
Pearson sparked a debate about a flag
change to replace the Union flag he
noticed that many Canadians battalions
included them maple leaf in their
insignia during World War one and this
is why he decided to make it a symbol of
this country in 1921 king george v made
red and white the official colors of
canada it was inspired by st. George's
Cross and the French royal emblem mrs.
Howell the Canadian flag was created
that we all know today Germany the
German flag stands out with its black
red and gold colours it dates back from
1840 when the Frankfurt Parliament
decided that they were the official
colors of Germany they said that it
represented democracy
that's because it was inspired by the
medieval banner of the Holy Roman Empire
it had a black eagle with two heads and
red crawls and a beat on a golden field
the three colors can also be associated
with the uniforms of the soldiers who
fought for their country during the
Napoleonic war it is just a great
example of how three simple colors can
mean a lot of things South Africa this
is probably one of the most colorful
flags that we have ever seen and once
again these colors all mean something
when Nelson Mandela was released from
prison in 1990 people asks for an
national flag for their country the
colors black yellow and green were
inspired by the banner of the African
National Congress Nelson Mandela's
political party the red white and blue
were taken from the flags of the
European colonists and there is also the
letter Y which represents the diversity
of the nation and their convergence
towards a unified path this flag is
pretty new as it was adopted recently in
1990 for China you immediately recognise
this flag but did you ever know what it
means
the color red actually represents the
Communist revolution in Japan then we
see the five stars the four smaller
stars represent the social classes of
the Chinese society the working class
the peasantry the urban petty
bourgeoisie and the national bourgeoisie
then we have the big star which is
another symbol of the Communist
revolution so we can see that this
country really wants to make it clear
that this is all about communism as they
had this flag since 1949 things seem to
be the same in this country so we don't
think that they are going to change
anytime soon
Vietnam as you can see this country was
really inspired by China they loved
their ceremonies and their symbols and
you can clearly see it when you look at
their flag they always liked the colors
red and yellow but the flag that we know
today was finally adopted by the
Communist Party of Vietnam in 1945
following World War two unfortunately
another war followed shortly after the
Republic of Vietnam started using a
yellow flag with three red horizontal
stripes in the south of the country but
when they lost the war the flag from
1945 finally came back and the
Democratic Republic of Vietnam we hope
that it will stay there because we don't
want to see people fighting again in
this country India we all love to eat
Indian food and watch some Bollywood
movies but there is so much more that
you need to know about this culture
their flag is also known as the Turanga
which means tricolour it was originally
meant to represent the two main
religious groups of the nation the red
was associated with the Hindus and the
green was associated with the Muslims
there was also a white stripe in the
middle to show that these two groups
could live together in peace you can
also see the will of law which
represents the endless circle of light
the flag evolves through time and
new meaning nowadays Japan this flag is
really simple and it is all we need to
understand that we are talking about the
Land of the Rising Sun and this is
exactly what is portrayed on this fly
when you look at the red dot the Sun has
been used on the Japanese flag since
1184 but it changed over the years the
Japanese have a philosophical approach
to all kinds of designs this is why we
love that their flag is simple and that
it has appropriate symbolism they also
like to see the hot color red with the
cold color white just like the circle of
the Sun contrasts with the rectangle of
the flag we love Japanese designs so we
knew that they were going to come up
with something great with their flag UK
we know that a lot of you come from the
United Kingdom so now it's time to talk
about the Union Jack it consists of the
cross of st. Patrick the red cross of
st. George and the salty air of st.
Andrews this is how they all reunited
together in the one flag Wales is also
part of the UK but it is not a part of
the Union Jack that's because at the
time when the flag was created Wales was
still part of the kingdom of England no
matter what we love the flag as it is so
we hope that it won't change anytime
soon
Australia have you ever wondered why the
whole flag of the United Kingdom was on
the Australian flag it represents the
colonisation by the British the big
seven pointed star on the left is also
known as the star of the Federation it
represents the country's six states and
the seventh one is for its territories
the stars on the right half of the flag
represent the Southern Cross
constellation visible from every state
and territory it is a beautiful thought
that wherever you are in this country
you just have to look up to the sky and
you know that your home Greece this flag
is as blue as the sea and as blue as the
buildings in this country but that would
be too easy this is not the real story
behind this flag during the revolution
many flags were displayed locally with a
lot of different colors they finally
chose the colors blue and white
in 1822 to express their dedication to
the Greek Orthodox faith the cross
symbolizes the wisdom of God freedom and
country then we have the nine horizontal
stripes which represents the nine
syllables and the battlecry of
Independence a picture can say a
thousand words and this is why we can
write the whole history of a country in
a simple flag Russia this flag was
simply inspired by the Dutch red white
blue tricolor
but the Russians rearranged it to make
it white blue red but other people were
more interested in giving it some
Russian symbolism they associated it
with the red shield of the Grand
Principality of Moscow with Saint George
cloaked in blue and mounted on a white
horse others also think that it's a
reference to the quartered flag of white
and red with a blue cross that was flown
on the first Russian warship it changed
a lot over the years but Russians
finally decided to stick to the white
blue red flag with so many
interpretations we'll just let you
choose your favorite Mexico we would
just love to see a beautiful taco on
this flag the Mexicans found something
better to represent their country it's
pretty simple as we can see three
vertical stripes in green white and red
the green represents hope and joy the
white is a symbol of peace and religion
and the red can be associated with the
independence of the nation then there is
the coat of arms which is a symbol of
the Aztec heritage of the nation there
is even a legend associated with this
flag the gods till the Aztec people to
settle at a location where they saw an
eagle feeding on a snake perched atop a
cactus this is where the city that is
now known as Mexico City was founded
Brazil the first thing that we think
about when we hear about this country is
all the festivals and when you look at
their flag you can clearly see that they
want to party all night long that's
because the white stars represent the
night sky over Rio de Janeiro but this
is not the most important meaning hidden
in this flag the motto on the Brazilian
flag is autumn eat Progresso it
translates to order and progress it was
inspired by the motto of the French
philosopher Auguste Comte love as a
principle and order as the basis
progress as the goal if there could be
one thing written on the flag of your
country what would it be don't be shy to
answer in the comment section down below
this country still uses symbols that
have origins that stretch back for
centuries the flag used to be white for
the coat of arms but King Charles the
third decided that the country needed to
stand out a little bit with more colors
the lion symbol has been used by a Roman
legion thousands of years ago there is
also the gold shield with four red bars
which is associated with a grandson of
Charlemagne when he was honoured the
count of Barcelona for his heroism
centuries ago on the coat of arms you
can also see the motto plus ultra which
means more beyond it represents the
discoveries by Spanish explorers it just
makes us want to learn more about the
coat of arms of our own country Denmark
what is really interesting about this
flag is that many people think that it
is the oldest flag in the world that we
still use today as it was created in
1219 the flag actually represents
Christianity and its influence on the
Nordic countries like Iceland Norway
Sweden and Finland this is why these
countries all have a similar flag
according to a legend the flag just fell
from the sky in 1219 when the King
defeated the Estonians but historians
don't believe in this theory they think
that the flag was actually just inspired
by old crusader banners will let you
believe in the story that you prefer
Malaysia
here's another flag that looks just like
the American flag it might be really
similar but it actually has a really
different meaning the 14 horizontal red
and white stripes just like the 14 arms
in the star actually represent the 13
Malaysian members and the federal
government it is a way to represent
their equality in status then we have
the crescent and the star symbol it
represents the most important religion
in this country Islam we also have two
important colors yellow is the
traditional royal color of the country
and blue represents the unity of people
in this country now that we know about
this we know that flags are much more
important than we thought Italy in
geography class everyone learned how to
know where this country was when our
teacher told us that it looks just like
a boot and we can also easily recognize
its flag as soon as we see it since the
twelve hundreds there were a lot of
flags and coats of arms to represent
this country this is why they decided to
create a flag that would have a meaning
for every
people the green white red tricolor was
presented in 1796 and the colors were
inspired by the uniforms of the urban
militia of Milan Italians were proud to
have a true flag of their homeland and
Italian troops carried the tricolour in
their battles France here we have
another tricolour with simply different
colors the French tricolour was inspired
by the red white and blue cockades worn
by King Louis the sixteenth during the
revolution white represents the French
royalty while red and blue can be
associated with Paris the national
capital nowadays they also represent
liberty equality and fraternity which
are the ideals of the French Revolution
this is how the country will remember
how they change the world forever what
was the flag of your country don't be
shy to tell us where you are from in the
comment section down below we'd love to
hear about you and that's it 420 flags
of the world and the stories behind them
for more stories like this make sure you
watch 50 million images and logos you
never noticed thanks for watching
[Music]